يعرف فايروس مارب باسم حمى مار برج
النزفيه وهي حمى شديده العدوى تنتمي الى
عائله مرض فيروس ايبولا الفيروس يتشابه مع
ايبولا من الناحيه الاكلينيكيه ويؤدي الى
احداث تفشيات وبائيه مع معدلات وفيات
عاليه وتنتج عدوى البشريه عند التعرض
المطول للمناجم او الكهوف التي تسكنها
مستعمرات خفافيش الفاكهه ويؤكد الاطباء
المتخصصون ان الانسان يبقى معديا ما دام
الفيروس موجودا في دمه ويستهدف الفيروس
الخلايا المناعيه في جسم الانسان ويتسبب
بعدم تنشيط الجسم بشكل صحيح لاستجابه
خلايا الدم البيضاء للفيروس
ولهذا الفيروس اعراض عديده تشبه
الانفلونزا لحد كبير ومنها الحمى والصداع
والقشعريره والام الجسم وايضا اليرقان او
اصفرار لون الجلد والعينين واحيانا الطفح
الجنسي
[موسيقى]